[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for lunch where we
sift through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use
in your everyday life hi i'm dan hanks
and i'm joined by my co-host dr greg
sadler
and today we're going to talk about
what's the upcoming season
of stoicism so every year in the month
of october and now it's actually going
into november
so you can identify it with fall there's
a lot of activity
around modern stoicism we have a big
conference called stoicon that happens
every year
this time of course it's virtually
because kovid
and there's a one week class that
thousands of people take called stoic
week it was originally called live like
a stoic
and and people do exactly that and then
there's all sorts of other cool events
happening
and what's what's really great about
this this year is that
so many of these events almost all of
them actually the only one that's that's
not
virtual is uh one in russia
that i guess they're less concerned
about kovit than than everybody else in
the world but
for the most part all these events are
virtual so even if they're
staged in australia or
you know like ours is here in milwaukee
anybody anywhere in the world can
participate that in them
provided i guess that they have the
right time zone so they're not you know
in the middle of the night or something
like that but even even night owls could
get in on it so
we have this this big season coming up
and dan and i thought we would
revisit stoicism since the episode that
we devoted to it we didn't get through
everything that we
we wanted to and there's also been a
recent development in the
the news that we're going to talk about
involving an unemployment or rather a
firing claim
in a foreign country and somebody using
stoicism
as what would you call it like a um an
excuse
a a cover for doing some rather unstoic
activities a shield
yeah that's a that's exactly it yeah so
i don't think stoicism was quite meant
to be used
that way but we'll we'll get to that so
right
you know one of the things that i'm
going to be doing a talk about
later on in this season is whether it's
okay for a stoic to get
excited about stoic week because in the
past
i've i've posted that you know i'm i'm
very i'm very much looking forward to it
i'm excited about stoic week or stoicon
and then i would have some people
criticizing me saying it's it's not
stoic
to be too excited about anything and
you know i've got some responses for
that but i'm curious to hear what
what you think about that is it is that
the wrong thing to do is that a
misunderstanding of what stoicism would
entail to
to get excited about something well i
guess you'd go to the one of the
pro-social emotions of the wish
and that you know you're wishing for
things that
have a like a high probability of
happening that
you know especially that are
under your control to a certain extent
um and since you're the one that's
organizing this
and you put all the wheels in motion
and there's so many of them going
forward that the probability that at
least one of these events will go on
is yeah um is is rather high and so
you know as long as you're not desiring
them to happen
that you desire what happens to happen
um you can still have these
goals and to uh it is
rational to think that these things will
happen
uh these are not outside of the norm
things yeah what we translate
as wish bulasis in in greek it
can be translated also as rational
desire so it's
desiring things but in a way that
actually makes sense rather than
you know so let's take stoic on for
example
in the past it was this big uh
face-to-face conference and you'd have
all these big speakers
who are well known in the stoic
community that's why it's a con
in the first place just like you know
any other thing whether it's comic books
or cars or
you know i guess sports so you know you
got these speakers and you get to meet
them
and you get to meet other people who are
interested in what you're interested in
and you go to workshops and you know
there's going to be some hassles of
course there'll be crowds and
maybe there'll be some people there are
kind of disagreeable there always are
um and you know maybe you know if you
have to fly like i went to
stoichons in toronto in uh
new york and in london and
i i chose not to go to greece because i
was like that's going to be way too much
hassle for me
to try to get there during the the
school year
so i didn't go to last year's but you
know when
any time that you're like stepping on a
plane's uh
you're walking through that that hallway
you know getting onto the plane
you know things can get screwed up and
probably will get screwed up something's
gonna go wrong right
so it's not rational to expect
everything to conform to your desires
but you can still say oh man i'm going
to get to meet so and so i'm going to
get to talk to this person
whose book i read i'm going to hear a
really great discussion about this with
this panel
i think that's something that a person
can look forward to
and you know and if it doesn't turn out
that well like let's say the speaker has
laryngitis and they they bring in
somebody else instead or they
they cancel that part of the event well
you know that's where the what we call
the reserve clause
comes in right right so we should we
should talk about that
the reserve clause is you know this is
something you see in i guess a number of
philosophies
as well as religions you know um in
christianity you'll often hear that
the saying god willing um and the
reserve clause within stoicism is
uh fate willing so what does that mean
though what's the difference between
fate and god
is is there a difference i guess it
depends on their
your person you're asking okay if you're
if you're a theist then
especially if you're of a certain
abrahamic base then
you know there is a plan and so i guess
god and fate would be directly
intertwined
if you go by like the ancient stoics
they
they refer to nature
and of the universe and zeus
and god um as all
kind of interchangeably and so um
nature's is to a certain extent fate and
that you know that is
the way that things will happen yeah
actually that's that's a good
launching point for bringing up
something so when we think about
religions and this case that we're going
to talk about does touch on stoicism
viewed as something almost like a
religion
we think about like prayer and rituals
and stuff like that
and and stoicism doesn't have that so if
you're getting on the plane
and suddenly um you know you're in the
air there's a big
jolt some turbulence and you look out
the window and like the engine's on fire
um and you're like oh that's that's bad
you know right goose flew into it or
something like that
um maybe a christian would would would
start praying at that point oh you know
wait suddenly i need to hold up okay is
it bad
if if uh a goose flies into the um
the engine well it's i mean from a stoic
perspective you're saying right
i mean yes it is you're talking about
it's certainly bad for the plane
it's really bad for the goose and you
know the stoics don't say that
that death is totally you know
indifferent right uh ideally you want
you want people not to die if you
but you shouldn't be living in fear of
death exactly yeah yeah
so the stoic you know wouldn't start
praying because
zeus isn't gonna change anything as zeus
has sort of like already
made it clear what's gonna happen but
so like either there's enough engines
still on the plane that you'll
eventually land and the pilots
can do it right right like hopefully
sully's in there right
and um or it's not and
um unless you have some like
control over the plane unless you're the
pilot here
uh or you can somehow do something to
materially
change the uh events that are happening
well then just kind of you know a more
pate you know
love fates you know that's that's
actually i mean we're talking about a
very literal thing but that's actually a
great metaphor
you're along for the ride on so much
right if you're not the pilot
or the co-pilot or somebody who actually
has a
pilot's license and training and and
maybe you know can step in and do
something
you're not you're not going to determine
what happens with that plane you can
decide you know when the oxygen mast
comes down to like panic or not
or put on your mass calmly but that's
about it
[Music]
how many pounds of newton pounds of
force do you want to exert on that like
hand rest as you're going down yeah i
suppose that's that's
within your power as well right i
i don't know yeah i don't really know um
what else i mean you could decide to
call the stewardess or the uh
flight attendant flight attendant yeah
over and say can i have uh
one more drink please you know that
might be something people would do
or uh yeah um
but i mean so that these are these are
some good examples of differences
between
theistic and then stoic ideas about
things there's
you know epictetus actually says hey you
can go do these rituals of divination if
you want to
but you probably should avoid it and
only do it if you like totally
can't figure it out on your own it's
almost like the today's thing
where people email you or
have comments and they ask you questions
and you're like man you can google that
you know why don't you do some work on
your own and figure it out
right uh it's sort of like the ancient
the stoic gods are saying you need to
figure this out on your own people
you're rational we gave you a rational
mind
it wasn't just for you to put aside and
then constantly bug
us with your questions it reminds me of
i believe it's chrysippus who
talks about the idea of fate and the way
that we
deal with fate in the uh
the vignette of a a dog
tied to the back of the wagon
now this this is probably not going to
be all that appealing
to the listeners i imagine well it's
kind of like
fate in this context is the wagon it's
going forward
and you are the dog and you can either
pull against your leash and fight
and you know curse at bait all you want
and get yeah or or you can kind of go
with it and so that's this
kind of central idea of like what is
under your control
yeah a lot of times it's the way that
you are looking at the world
and not your ability to actually change
you know something that
and it may have been a part of that
original idea because we don't we don't
have like chrysippus writings
if you think about it if if you are that
dog and you're running alongside the
wagon
where it's going now you actually have
some play you could like go this way or
that way
up to how far the leash is whereas if
you're just allowing yourself to be
dragged while you're at the end of the
leash and you're going wherever the
wagon goes and you're not going to be
able to have any
any real scope for things you know i
guess
i'd always kind of added that on maybe
that was just me
reading into it but yeah i i'd
absolutely agree with
the idea that there is you know there
is room to play with the leash
and the amount that you're given yeah
that's kind of uh that makes it a little
bit more of an attractive
prospect then maybe it's kind of like
the idea that we're all
on this earth and we can go and do
anything that we want on this earth
but that earth is gonna still rotate
around the sun
yeah until we're all dead and we have
lots of play and we can do
lots of really cool things but there's
almost nothing that we're ever going to
do to change the
you know the vast order of things yeah
yeah
and i think too another thing you can
say about that is there's there's
certain
constants of human nature
that you you can't i mean you can try to
push against them but
they're always going to come back at you
and you can't really avoid them
so you know like people think that they
can do
bad things and it's just this once and
it's not really going to have any
lasting effects in the world and it's
not actually going to like affect their
character
but that's not the way things were made
you know and you might be able to get
away with something
once and you're lucky that it doesn't
have a bad effect but but sooner or
later you do bad things it's going to
lead to
to bad effects and it's going to affect
you as a person as well
likewise you know doing good things and
it's not just that the bad effects
are external bad effects it's not just
like
the legal system or someone's going to
come back and like try the exact same
revenge but it's also
it's changing your character and
the decisions that you make because you
are kind of what you repeatedly do
right yeah i think this is um
something that stoics were very attuned
to the force of habit
in producing sort of reliably good or
bad
actions and not just actions but ways of
reading the situation
ways of motivating ourselves ways of
prioritizing
that's that's a really important point
although i mean you you can find that in
most virtue ethics i i'd say
right yeah not only just habits but also
reviewing those habits to you know
review your day or
your week and try to think back because
a lot of times it's
you know you're in the moment and
because we already have
a number of habits that are built in
from our
upbringing yeah that those things
uh have to kind of be unlearned if we
find them to be bad
and a lot of times we do them
unconsciously yeah so that's that's a
good point and now you're bringing that
out of stoicism right that's that's a
stoic
practice that's kind of basic uh this
review
at certain times of the day you know
it's actually a
like the the review that marcus aurelius
uses is actually cripped from
the pythagorean that's right right it
goes way back further than that
so yeah so that's the um what have i
done well
what have i failed at what could i do
better yeah
that's that's often quite helpful to do
as a practice and at first like most
things it feels weird and
you don't you don't really want to do it
even though you've told yourself that it
would be a good thing for you to do but
after a while it becomes
it becomes your normal routine right
part of your your how you finish up the
day yeah and it's
it's really like if you have
trouble sleeping sometimes it's just
those thoughts
running through your head and getting
them down on paper
are useful and one of the things that
usually runs through people's heads
are them ruminating about the actions
and the
interactions that they have with other
people in the world that day
yeah i think something that probably
keeps a lot of people up at night too is
like what they didn't do or what they
forgot
to do um so
that's why i also write in my journal
all the things that i want to do
tomorrow
so that one i don't forget them and two
um that i don't have to think about what
i'm doing the next day yeah you
externalize or you get it out of your
head so to speak right
right so yeah you know we've already
talked about a couple different
important stoic practices just in this
uh
little segment here then um
do we want to hit on on any any other
one in particular
um i know we saved one for the end right
yeah i
i think we should talk uh about the idea
of being pro-social within
stoicism yeah this is this is something
that
i would say we can't stress enough
because there's so many
misunderstandings about this
particularly just coming from the word
stoic with like a lowercase s that
people use today
to describe somebody who's unattached
unemotional
you know um not not engaged with other
people
withdrawing from everybody else and
that's that's just not stoicism it would
you know
as the philosophy stoicism with a
capital s at all right
it looks like you you're getting a
passage ready you got something
okay go ahead um
so this is from marcus aurelius's
meditations
it's my favorite passage from the book
book two
first section and halfway through it
goes you know
um nor can i be uh
nor can i feel angry at my relative or
hate him
these people that he has to deal with
that are unhelpful and
annoying to say the least
um but we were born to work together
like
two feet hands and eyes like the two
rows of teeth
upper and lower to obstruct each other
is unnatural
to feel anger at someone to turn your
back on him these are obstructions
now what does that mean for for the the
listener obstructions
uh there are obstructions to uh one's
own well-being as well as obstructions
to
kind of the order of things as this idea
of
a cosmopolitanism a um that we are all
part of a a larger tribe a tribe of
you know rational agents
yeah that's that we are we should be
working together
to benefit us all yeah i think that's
that's that's a key stoic idea epictetus
uses the metaphor of like bodily parts
as well and talks about you know if a
foot were to say i don't want to go in
the mud
i want to be you know beautiful like the
eye it's not a very good foot at all you
know
yeah it's got a totally different
function and so
you know we we've all got our parts to
play
and you know we play those parts better
when we're not trying to
make our own position be the the one
that matters the most
um when we're actually working in
cooperation with other people imagine if
the foot was like i don't want this
blood coming from all these other parts
of the
the body you know i don't know where
that stuff has been those
you know those dirty fingers and you
know organs look at
you know look at how gross they are
inside i i just want my the blood that
i've got here i mean it wouldn't last as
a foot very long
so no and it
um it kind of hammers home
the idea that uh
not only like each part has a function
that is necessary to work together
that um that we should
not be i guess uh looking down on those
people just because of the positions
that they're holding
that they we all have a place to play
for the betterment of us all and that
there shouldn't be
any real derision for any person that
has a place in society
that is beneficial to society yeah
that's that's a really good way of
putting it
um i mean i i can't think of any
classic stoic passage that comes to mind
about that except where epictetus talks
about
um slaves and he was a slave himself and
he says
that it's well actually seneca talks
about about slaves in a similar light as
well he says we have to look at these as
human beings
which is kind of a radical way to talk
at the time
and each one of them is in a certain way
just as good as us
because they've got this he talks
epictetus
speaks in very religious terms they've
got this little piece of god inside of
them the
rational part um but he's shard of the
divine
without going into god talk i think we
could say
everyone by virtue of being a human
being
participates in this this you know basic
human nature of rationality
and it's not just like cold calculating
you know turn your emotions off
rationality
properly oriented and developed emotions
are part of
human rationality as well you know
and so there i guess there is something
like that but what you said is
it goes beyond that a little bit i'd say
maybe that's just my modern reading of
it
so that's actually that's a good you
know we said we weren't going to talk
about the difference between ancient and
modern
stoicism but it kind of raises that
question
do we need to reinterpret this stuff
today
um i i'd say yes
i think you probably would say yes too
right
yeah especially because we have so
little of the original texts if
whenever someone says like this is
exactly it
and when we don't even have some like
the really foundational
like xenos republic yeah like you know
we don't have anything the guy wrote
unfortunately right yeah yeah
we none of the first couple founders we
have any of their books you know like
uh xenocrystipis or clianthes yeah
the first three heads of the stoa like
all we got are like
quotes from other in other people's
books yeah little fragments
sometimes a paragraph of chrysippus and
galen
who is a a medical guy but he's always
quoting chrysippus to say how wrong
chrysippus is
was that when he was talking about the
heart being the center of rationality oh
yeah you know there was a big
there's a bit of a side note right there
there was a big discussion
in in ancient times about whether it was
the brain or whether it was the heart
and a lot of ancient philosophers
held out for it being the heart as a
matter of fact they seem to
some of them seem to have imagined the
brain was almost like a cooling system
or something
uh now plato is a radiator yeah i mean
it kind of looks like
i mean who knows but do they have
radiators i don't think so but i i don't
know where they got that idea but
um they you know they thought of the
heart as being the center of the human
being
plato didn't buy into that because the
rational part for him
is in the head and then like the the
irrational parts are below the neck
but i think a lot of the other
philosophers
identified it with the heart right
so so but yeah so so going back do we
this reinterpretation business right
why do we have to reinterpret the stuff
that we have
isn't it good enough just to read
epictetus and marcus aurelius and seneca
and then just
just apply it i don't i don't think so
because we
we live in a fundamentally different
world than they do that we there are
certain
on political and environmental
differences that are just so
absolutely alien to them yeah that it
requires at least some you know uh
fitting into the the modern milieu
so this is probably something you've
thought about
quite a bit over the years then
obviously some things we want to we want
to sort of say well that was
of their time and we're not really that
interested in it like you know epictetus
insistence that men should have beards
or else they
they're either effeminate or things like
that i think we could probably say
nah i mean although you and i both have
beards we can we can recognize the
beardless is
still still you know
men right and we don't have to stick
with the rigid gender roles that they
had
and there's there's other weird you know
like things
here and there where we read a passage
we're like well that doesn't i don't
know that we have to
buy into that how do we tell
what we what we should keep what what is
still
as true today as it was 2 000 years ago
so i'm i'm more of an empiricist than
i'm a rationalist okay
and so um i i'm very much in favor
of you know study and research
and um and repeatable
large uh sample size studies
for some of these things and if there is
reliable
repeatable and repeated experimentation
that some of these things
don't actually hold then i'm going to
drop them those things
you know it's kind of like
the stokes are really great on a lot of
things that are kind of psychologically
based because we
as a species haven't changed much in the
last 2000 years
okay but they have a lot of stuff about
the cosmos
do not hold to any at all because it is
way outside of what we have been
able to experimentally demonstrate
yeah and i think that some of these
things just given the way that we
conceive of the cosmos
there's no way they're gonna work right
um so for example and on the nature of
the gods which is
you know the closest thing we have to
stoic theology
and cosmology you know you've got zeus
who's like this
capital g god and then you've got all
these other
let's call them godlets or godlings and
they seem to perform a role
similar to what angels were thought to
do
in you know early uh christian and
muslim stuff and and
you know governing the universe and
making sure like everything goes the way
it's supposed to go but
do we do we really have any evidence
that there's anything like this in
contemporary cosmology no i think we
have to like throw all that stuff away
um just just as much as we would with
you know more theistic conceptions
that that just seems to go by the
wayside
as well as the the conflagration
oh well we should say what that is yeah
so that is the
the porosity is how it's called in greek
right
so let's say again ekporosis
yeah and so this is um the idea that
uh our world is actually our entire
cosmos
which is all things um goes through
a uh a rebirth and burning
in giant cycles of you know i don't know
milli
honey hundreds of thousands or millions
of years yeah who
who knows they have a conception of
matter
on that you know everything kind of like
goes
up into eventually it burns up and then
the thing that like
flame burns into is reason and so the
entire yeah of
all all everything because it's like
it's all getting sucked back
up into into this like pure fire and
then it
yeah re becomes new again
it gets reborn yeah into a new version
of the universe and it happens
exactly the same way as fate has
predicted because
fate is perfectly reasonable and
that uh it has defined the exact best
way
that everything should happen yeah you
know there's a passage in
epictetus discourses where i think he's
kind of joking around actually
because he's he is so often he's talking
to an interlocutor and he's saying
man your ideas are wrong and let me give
you
give you an instance to show you how
wrong they are and he's talking about
it's in the it's in the chapter on
solitude and whether solitude is
something good or bad for us right
and and epictetus tells us something
that a lot of other ancient authors have
said
solitude is really easy to bear if
you're a good person because you like to
be with yourself
if you're a bad person you don't like to
be with yourself and so
solitude then becomes something
difficult to bear and the other thing
that can make solitude bad is we feel
like we're going to be resourceless like
we're not going to have any
friends or we're not going to have what
we need to be able to get through things
and so he says when the conflagration
happens
do you think zeus is like crying to
himself because
all the other gods are gone and
everything else is gone
no he's fine he's he's cool being by
himself
until everything starts up again so
presumably
epictetus thought of you know this this
thing is happening
or maybe maybe he didn't maybe he just
thought his audience did
uh in any case he refers to it and he's
got this funny line about
you know imagine if like zeus was like
all
sad and morose because nothing exists
anymore you know
and and he's sort of like whining not
much of a god then is he
right and so once again these are
certain things that we
have decided that with from within
ancient stoicism that
it could probably be thrown to the
dustbin of history yeah
i like your idea that a lot of the
psychological stuff
um still holds and and some of it does
seem to be
you know more and more borne out by what
we're
discovering through looking at the brain
and how it works and and
you know therapeutic techniques in
psychology and what actually is
evidence-based
you know the whole cognitive revolution
uh is
it aligns very nicely with with stoic
conceptions of
rationality and emotions so yeah yeah
they had lots of time to sit around and
talk to each other about
what they're thinking how they're
experiencing the world and that's
been our main way until you know only
the last 20 years
of you know investigating our our
own consciousnesses yeah and i'm gonna
say something and it'll be a little bit
of a rant here
i think a lot of people imagine like
everybody before the dawn of science in
the early modern period
as being these people who just like they
didn't do any real experimentation or
observation
and that's nuts i mean aristotle was was
an
empiricist in this respect he liked
cutting animals open and seeing what was
in their guts that's why
alexander who was his patron sent back
all these these animals from
you know the places that that alexander
was marching around he had hunters along
for that
and they were they were similarly doing
that with with human beings they would
observe things like
again aristotle he he you know in effect
he's he's
plato you could say is founding
political science in a certain sense but
aristotle founded it
by actually looking at what each
greek city state what its constitution
was and then writing
or at least maybe he didn't necessarily
write it maybe some of his students
write it
writing out these treatises and
establishing like a research program
and allowing him to make you know
interesting generalizations
and the stoics did exactly the same
thing they they were not just like
coming up with a bunch of ideas and then
saying all right how can we impose these
on everybody
and you know make make them fit no they
look at how people behave and they they
saw what worked and what didn't work
in terms of uh moving people away from
destructive habits and towards you know
healthier and more productive habits
uh and eventually towards you know what
they call eudaimonia that
we now call like happiness or
fulfillment or
you know being okay um yeah and that was
like the major
question at the time like there's at
least a major philosophical question
in ancient greece especially in athens
we have the stoics we have the cynics we
have the
epicureans we have you know to a certain
extent the
the lyceum and the rheum's i'm all
asking
what makes a good life and so there was
a lot of like
investigation into that particular
question you know so let's come back to
the pro-social thing again
um can you have a good life
in isolation or let's even go further
than that
being indifferent to or being in
conflict with with other people
some people thrive on drama right is is
that is that a good life
i don't believe thriving a drama is a
good life
not i guess specifically from a stoke
point of view
um then your uh the basis of your
happiness
uh is an external and the stokes say
that
your basis for a good life or your own
happiness
should be from within yeah
and so i guess the stoic would say that
you could have
a good life by yourself um
but it might yeah might be preferable to
be with other people just because we are
a social creature yeah for example there
were a lot of
um famous stoics who wound up getting
exiled
right uh uh sonia's rufus got exiled
twice i think
um seneca yeah and also seneca had to
write
letters of consolation to other people
who got exiled as well
right and then he was told to commit
suicide
true yeah and and cicero had to go into
exile
not exactly a stoic but he followed the
stoics in a lot of things
um so you know the idea is you should be
able to handle
being on your own but
there's more to life than than just you
know withdrawing to some
barren rock and living an ascetic life
you know deprived of other people so
what's the other side of that what's
what's involved with this pro-social
part
um this i guess
it could bring up uh okiosas which is a
idea of um appropriating the
um not the desires but the
uh affection well-being yeah of of
others
into your own as much as you can and so
um it's described as a a number of
concentric circles by i believe heracles
yeah describes it this way and uh where
you are at the center
and then your next circle is like your
parents and maybe your closest
siblings and then after that is your
extended family after that is your
neighborhood after that is your
your city their nation and then the
world and then maybe the cosmos or like
the
the realm of all rational creatures yeah
the idea of okiosis is to try to um
you know you might not succeed but try
to extend
the uh thinking about the
consequences of your actions to the same
extent that you would
uh think about the consequences of your
actions and how they would affect
those people closest to you and so
you're trying to can
contract these circles down to you yeah
you could say that
if there if there are emotions
associated with wichiosis
it's love or affection right
and concern or care um
you know aristotle who's not a stoic
talks about
friendship as if you if you want a
genuine friendship
it has to involve wishing well to the
other for their own sake not for the
sake of what you're getting out of them
not because they're an important person
who's going to save the universe but
just because they they matter
you know and that's why he says like you
can't be friends with salt for example
because salt
you know you can you can eat it as much
as you like and really like it but you
don't care about it for its own sake the
way you can
a person and the stoics acknowledge this
emotion
that in greek is called philostorgia and
it gets translated as familial affection
but it really can pertain to anybody who
were
were attached to it's translated
sometimes as fondness
and so oikiosis would be an extension of
that deliberately
from the people who we already feel that
about to people who we don't already
feel that about
and then eventually with time can come
to feel that way
um and remember we did a show about this
a while back i don't remember exactly
what episode it was but you talked about
buddhist meta meditation as being
similar to this
with the concentric circles and then if
i remember
yeah go ahead um peter sellers his book
uh the expanding circle which is
yeah very similar but expanding
effective
altruism uh and utilitarianism tied in
with that so this is kind of a
cross-cultural concept isn't it it is
uh and one of those things that made me
like look into buddhism just see like
what are
the other things that might be oh i
don't know that
oh yeah a little bit you know i'm not
super versed but i've read a couple
books now
so so that was the thing that got you
interested
in that that um concentric circles of
meta meditation
um that and i i came upon
um a book that looked at stoic or sorry
buddhism
through a um a scientific lens and it
says
like basically we've done some uh uh
training studies do you remember the
name yeah it's called
why buddhism is true that's right yeah
yeah
um i don't know where i put it
it's around here someplace um but yeah
i thought it was a really interesting
way of looking
at that and kind of you know breaking
the the wheat from the chaff
i'm getting into things that i can say
oh yeah there is
um some you know good scientific backing
on these ideas
yeah it's a and from you know i would
say from
from a typical stoic perspective um
actually lawrence becker talks about
this in a new stoicism when talking
about
um how to interpret the stoics
insistence on living in accordance with
nature and becker says that's a terrible
phrase
it's too bad that the stoics are stuck
with it because it's so it could mean so
many different things
and then he decides that part of it
means
living in accordance with the facts or
living in accordance with
the best knowledge that we have about
the cosmos
our bodies our psychology
you know that any any real as he calls
it a new stoicism
any real stoicism would have to
be adaptable so if we find out that i
don't know some
key stoic practice is actually harmful
according to becker we should abandon it
so i feel like this is a really good
segue into
three disciplines and specifically the
discipline of ascent
unless there's something you really need
to talk about i thought you were going
to
talk about the case that will will in a
couple of minutes because that's a
person who
clearly misunderstood something about
stoicism but
um yeah let's talk about the three
disciplines and then let's let's talk
about that
that interesting uh situation
so specifically um so the three uh stoke
disciplines
as put forward i believe by epictetus
right right
um our desire action in a sense and the
our three kind of categories of
looking and interacting with the world
that help uh
that support each other kind of like a
tripod um
and that you kind of have to have all
three of them in the stoic sense of
these
for kind of the whole philosophy to work
well
yeah and and the scent is all about
being aware of the world and
investigating it as best you can
you know there are you know they knew
about optical illusions even back then
and so they knew that like you look out
and
like maybe the tree kind of looks weird
like it's
bent but then you like walk around it
and you realize it's just like
a weird way it was growing it's not
actually bent or it's just like the the
bark
looked weird and so it's like yeah you
see all these things
and you you have these first impressions
but you need to reserve
um just ascending to these things just
because you see them
um otherwise you're going to you'll find
yourself in a world of hurt because
there are
lots of things that we interact with the
world where our first
impressions are absolutely incorrect
and our second and thirds too right yeah
and so i think
um he's like what was the the the idea
of the hand
like oh that's coming from zeno yeah
yeah
like this is like uh the impression this
is
like uh knowing and this is
understanding
something along those lines yeah an
ascent ascent enters in there and this
actually by the way this this um
treatment of so like the stoics would
say that
you you've got like these impressions
that come in and then there's
a moment where we decide whether we're
going to give in to them or not whether
we're going to like
withdraw a little bit from them and then
sort of assess them or test them or
you know before we we entertain them or
we can ascend to them automatically
and then afterwards there's the
consequences of doing that
this made its way into
a lot of non-stoic thought within
the middle ages so you see this same
pattern being worked out why because the
medieval monks
read seneca and cicero because they they
they copied them you know they they like
those those pagan authors
and uh so stoicism found its way into
the psychology of the middle ages as
well
and then this is also where we get the
uh what serenity prayer from
yeah i suppose you should stoke that
into christianity
you know another thing this this is a
bit of a side note
another thing that made its way in
through the monastic culture was um
uh some of the aesthetic practices you
know
were just like taking wholesale out of
stoic ideas and then just
you know these monks are like well this
stuff works let's use it you know
we're not going to just reject it
because it's not coming straight out of
the bible
they were way more judicious when it
came to that they realized you had to
synthesize
uh things that that you could you could
use
uh yeah there's even traditions of on
meditation and some ancient monastic
traditions that got
weeded out as not being christian at
some point in time
yeah i mean it depends it really depends
on like who's in charge
of determining what counts you know and
some of that had to do with religious
orders
um kind of sticking it to each other
so the older religious orders sometimes
are at a disadvantage compared to the
younger ones you know but this is where
this is where i'm like
liable as somebody who's like a
medievalist to get into some
some you know not only get into the
weeds but also get into stuff where i've
got some real strong opinions because
because i'm a big fan i'm a big
proponent of the benedictines against
the
the dominicans and franciscans and later
jesuits but that's a whole
different side so maybe we should talk
about the discipline of desire
what you should be desiring in this
moment what i should be
uh under a stoic idea of desire i'm just
trying to guess
yeah well i mean the stoic idea the
stoic discipline of desire
is what's really liberating about it i
think a lot of people think that
i just desire what i desire and it also
includes aversions i'm averse to what
i'm averse to and
that's just the way i'm made and the
stoics say no
you're really malleable you know by
directing your attention
by using uh things to remind yourself
of what the consequences are you can
change
how you desire things you can't of
course like flip a switch or take a pill
or put a chip in your head and
automatically desire the right things
but you can
you can wean your well yeah we'll see
about that
you can wean yourself away from bad
things and towards towards better things
um this is what like we were talking
about just earlier about
habits and creating these habits by
doing them over and over
right you instill certain
actions that then become second nature
you know an epictetus talks i've been
mentioning epictetus a lot tonight but
he is my favorite stoic so
that's probably why um as a matter of
fact let me look before i i say what
epictetus is going to say
who's your favorite stoic do you have
one
um i guess it's marcus aurelius
i was i was thinking it probably was
like i guess
as a a pure like prose
i love marcus aurelius okay
and yeah epictetus is a little bit more
dry
although he has some really like gut
busters everything else in a while
and i think because he's so dry a lot of
other times
it kind of like amplifies their like oh
he's making a joke here like real
hardcore yeah
um so let me ask why not seneca
uh seneca's next okay
just because he's i love the the letters
and it's like
just this correspondence that goes on
forever it's kind of like
it's uh at least the letters to lucilius
are
almost like a a course in stoicism
yeah i find that to be really enjoyable
to read
yeah that's that's a great way to put it
i think that's part of why they were
preserved in the form that they were
because they were held to be
like almost covering every every topic
you could think of
the other thing that's really cool about
those letters i'll say too
is that we know i mentioned like you
know
chrysippus we we know about him in part
because galen
you know talked about him in order to to
go against him
we also know about chrysippus from what
epictetus
and and then even more seneca have to
say there's
passages where he'll quote chrysippus
or other authors like posidonius you
know a middle stoic
sometimes we get passages but we also
get a lot of summaries where he'll say
well you know as we all know
posed onions taught this and and seneca
is like the only place where we've got
anyone telling us so we're like well we
didn't all know but thank goodness you
wrote it down
you know so well with the epic titus so
the habit thing right i was just to say
epictetus tells us that
when we're in a tempting situation we
should remind ourselves
we're not just deciding for right now
we're deciding
whether to strengthen or weaken a habit
and i think that's a really helpful
thing to
i know for me it's very helpful to keep
that in mind when i'm tempted to
justify what i'm doing so speaking of
justification i've mentioned a couple
times this interesting case
of a guy samuel jackson not the
actor but a guy who worked for
little which is a german
firm that they find in in they're all
across
um europe and the grocery store right
yeah and in this case
it was a guy who was apparently in
communications and said some bad things
about his co-workers
um and then was told to apologize made a
bad apology got fired
and then claimed that he did it because
of stoicism
so this is actually just quoting from
personnel today an article about this
he argued that his philosophical beliefs
formulated by zeno of kittium
uh and taught in ancient athens meant he
must adhere to the truth without fear of
offending other people
now stoicism does say that we should
adhere to the truth
it doesn't say that well we shouldn't
fear offending other people
but we also shouldn't offend other
people we shouldn't deliberately go out
of our way to say things
as he did that are racist and then um
you know would certainly affect his
co-workers
and then uh not apologize properly
for it and so it's interesting because
the judge
actually said that stoicism
uh counts as a philosophy now it's not
like here in the united states where
it's
it would have to be like covered under
the first amendment and religion
in this case in britain a a philosophy
like say veganism
can be a sufficient reason why you're
treating people differently
the funny thing about this is the guy's
getting stoicism wrong and the judge
didn't seem to
to catch that right
[Music]
and they even they even end up
uh like quoting the stanford
encyclopedia philosophy
which i think is actually getting
stoicism wrong too
um so it's it's unfortunate because
the what this guy is doing is definitely
not stoicism
you know saying racist remarks about
about co-workers
not not a stoic thing to do doubling
down pro-social
yeah definitely i mean and there's no
like
there's no like well why did you do this
why why would you say this sort of thing
he clearly thinks that the racist remark
is is a true remark
so and he's yeah and he's he's making a
uh a
statement that has facticity yes he's
saying
um that a a certain group is greasy
um and that that is a a fact
a a statement sorry
it is a statement that has the ability
to be proven true or false
and it is demonstrably false yeah and so
he is unwise to be uh choosing to
stick to his guns on this yeah and any
good stoic
would when confronted by other people
saying wow you're a jerk
would like look at themselves and say am
i a jerk
what did you know let me think about
this behavior on my part what are my
motivations
for saying these things that are
offensive i think this is something
that's kind of interesting because this
is
something really important to personal
development
it requires us to have a sense of
humility being willing to acknowledge
when we've got something wrong and
marcus aurelius is somebody who says
hey if i'm wrong about something let me
know so i can fix it
this guy is is like the opposite of that
right
right he's planted his laying the ground
for a really poor
place and decided he's gonna have to
defend that hill
come you know heck or high water yeah
yeah that's
and we talk about a hill to die on um
it's not actually stoic to do that
the what would make a hill worth dying
on is that
it's it's like you know it embodies
something of
high value like you're protecting people
or
um you're actually doing your duty to
to your country or something along those
lines
so for example if you're you know uh
when you join the
the government or the armed services in
this country you are
uh sworn to protect and defend the
constitution that's right
there is a duty to you know potentially
do things
that would be against the wishes of your
like commanding officers
if it conflicts with this thing that you
have sworn to do
that's true yeah and actually all i can
remember you know i was
in the army and i remember that we were
told we're not supposed to obey
unlawful orders you know that
and there was discussion about you know
well what is an a lawful order what's an
unlawful order most of the orders that
you get are
are lawful but if they tell you like hey
we're going to like pick some guy at
random and beat the
the tar out of him that's an unlawful
order
i mean you could have some some cases
where
it could somehow be construed to be the
right thing i mean that's what a few
good men was about
that whole movie right um but you have
to do some reasoning there
and so yeah this is a great case of
somebody who's
using stoicism as as you put it a shield
um in order to cover up bad actions
on on his part that a stoic a genuine
stoic would would be condemning
no and also his epistemology is really
bad
or his
yeah uh so from the stoix perspective
that would they they called that part
logic right and that's where the
designer of ascent also came in
or the discipline of ascent um you
studied
how to tell true statements from false
statements how to tell good inferences
from
bad inferences and you know any sort of
sweeping stereotype
i mean there are some cases where a few
stereotypes might actually be correct
but we'd have to be really really
careful to figure out which of those
they are
and i think in this day and age we
should probably assume that any
sweeping statement about an entire class
of people
is probably going to be false right
there's just
there's too many people and people are
way too varied to have any
of those statements really you know
besides like
we're all human thus will die yeah
so um do we want to get into the
the question we're going to have to run
through that in the practice pretty
quickly
or do we just want to jump right to the
practice i did have somebody who
who who uh messaged me on twitter today
with an interesting
story let's do the question quick okay
so uh somebody
messaged me and he said i was wondering
how a stoic outlook would reflect on
mental health conditions
vis-a-vis how we treat them in terms of
medication i understand that none of
this pharmaceutical
advancement was present at the height of
stoic philosophy but just how
out of principle how might we think
about this i was thinking in terms of
whether taking mind altering medication
would be viewed as unvirtuous
contradicting a person's responsibility
to take a hold of their personal pain
and so you know this is a great example
of what you were talking about earlier
where
you know a modern interpretation of
stoicism is going to differ from
an ancient interpretation but even then
if if they
like if epictetus um was you know knew
that somebody
had some sort of chemical imbalance in
their brain and probably needed
something to even them out to some
degree i don't think he would have been
against it
i don't think i totally agree tough it
out you know
like i look at uh stoicism as the things
that help us
you know once our brains are in like a
fairly neurotypical
oh at least chemical basis you know that
you know we
have these i guess uh what did
uh freud call them or neuroses or
whatever you know these these we're now
thinking about the world
that are purely just you know the
patterns that we have developed
and not a a fundamentally medical
problem with
our brain as an organ yeah now we use
the word disorder
um but you're right and some things
you know are going to be caused by
organic issues
and some will be caused by trauma that
might require psychotherapy that's not
going to be helped just by doing stoic
exercises you know
and and some things can be addressed by
by philosophical practices but we have
to be able to discern between those
those things
and i i kind of think that a combination
can often be quite helpful i look at a
lot of
psychiatric medicine as essentially
giving people crutches
you know it's it's great when you get a
crutch
but the crutch by itself doesn't heal
your leg it helps you get around
so it helps you have the mobility that
you need but you're going to have to do
some
some physical therapy as well and the
physical therapy is doing either the
psychotherapy or the stoic
uh work right so if all you do is take
you know let's say you're depressed
right
um and you just take a bunch of
antidepressants well that's nice it'll
keep
it'll keep you even for a while but you
might actually want to look at
why you're depressed what other things
besides just you know brain states
um are are involved in that like you
know if you find out that like every
relationship that you had
crashed and burned and look at the fact
that you know you're the only
constant in that and then you're like oh
i better look at how i
interact with people maybe stoicism can
actually help with that you know
yeah i totally agree and uh practice
yeah why don't you lead us through
through so our
practice this week is that of the
mistaken imprints
and it was put forward this way you know
someone comes up to you and says
i make more money than you therefore i
am better than you
and you can retort well the horse runs
faster than you
therefore is the horse better than you
this is this question of like what
is the actual good here if you
kind of desire money to be a good
but does that just because you desire to
be good does it actually
make it a good yeah so
we're pretty much out of time now so do
we want to
lead out on a final thought or we'll
lead out with the word
fetus people are upset not by things but
their judgment
about things
[Music]
you